I mean Larry Elder when he were here way
talked about the fact that uh inner city
black men or black communities are
disproportionately affected by illegal
immigration because of the disruption to
the economy I think Al ultimately you
can also say that this is sort of one of
the like like I remember being in high
school and having this conversation with
someone he was like well you're not
going to pick food out of a farm and you
want to be like so you admit that you
see them as inferior workers you know
how much you know here to do
backbreaking labor fruit harvesting gets
paid like uh this was this was 10 years
ago I went to arms in California 15 to
20 bucks an hour mhm no joke and they
had illegal immigrants working there I
talked to some uh young kids who were
skateboarding and I asked them like you
know what do you think about's going on
there's these controversies and they
said their parents are uh undocumented
and so they were born here but their
parents they they work and they're
scared about what's going to happen with
Trump and all that and I was like how
much do you how much do you guys make
picking fruit here and they're like uh
like $15 starting but if you've been
here for a while it's like 20 bucks an
hour and I'm like I know a lot of
Americans who would love to make 20
bucks an hour just picking fruit